[Musique]
si pierre palmade est connu de toutes
les générations pour ses sketchs
mythique dans les années 90 et ses
pièces de théâtre aux côtés de muriel
robin et michèle laroque
il est beaucoup plus discret sur sa vie
privée pourtant le confinement lui a
visiblement fait changé d'avis puisqu'il
a décidé de se confier au jdd
et s'il est hypocondriaque l'humoriste
arrive tout de même à garder le sourire
dans cette période donc ce gène je
parviens à rester léger même si le jt me
ramène sur terre je n'ai pas d'enfant et
du kenny deux conjoints à supporter il
faut dire que pierre palmade ne risque
pas d'avoir quiconque à supporter
puisque c'est seul qu'il a décidé de
vivre ce confinement une solitude qui
pourtant semble lui peser j'aimerais
vraiment avoir un compagnon sur du long
terme ça doit être cool
une prise de conscience que l'humoriste
a eu après avoir décidé de mettre fin
aux abus qui le rongeait depuis des
années quand on arrête l'alcool et la
drogue
l'amour s'impose à vous comme un espoir
j'observe les couples et je les envie je
n'en peux plus de passer d'un garçon à
un autre il faut dire que la dernière
fois que pierre palmade a reçu un garçon
chez lui les choses ne se sont pas très
bien passées le jeune homme avait accusé
à tort pierre palmade de tentative de
viol
de fausses accusations qui lui ont valu
trois mois de prison avec sursis et 500
euros d'amendé
quant à pierre palmade il avait été
poursuivi pour usage de stupéfiants
[Musique]
mathieu mon chéri on avait donc qu'un
pas mal c'est vrai que il ya pas mal de
gens aussi qui réfléchissent à leur vie
j'ai l'impression pendant ce confinement
et qu'ils istèque j'ai fait des erreurs
je referai pas peut-être pas la même
chose c'est aussi le temps aussi de
réfléchir un peu j'ai l'impression même
jean luc et toitures mita d'état des
regrets toit de ce que tu penses à des
trucs parce que tu disais des choses que
je n'aurais pas dû faire
est-ce que tu regrettes des trucs dans
ta vie là on serait qu on déconne mais
c'est des trucs aussi qu'on a envie de
se dire est convoqué et qu'on se marre
sans ce fameux franchement c'est pas
tellement par rapport aux à ma vie
amoureuse c'est ce que je pense qu'on a
que ce qu'on mérite quelque part donc je
pense que si je suis célibataire
aujourd'hui ces quelques pages des biens
chercher circo voilà j'ai d'instable
j'ai fait des conneries
donc j'ai mérité qu'on petit voilà où
tout je quitte donc ça je me plains pas
de ça même si j'espère toujours
retrouver un grand amour
mme hermange on réfléchit plutôt assis à
ma vie de ma vie par an voilà je n'ai
pas été assez présent de pages pas été
assez présent et mes enfants et je pense
particulièrement ce moment ce que je
dois pas parce que je veux pas le risque
est décontaminé
je les vois pas et la période me pèse en
plus mes enfants et mes équipes ou coûts
explique voilà ce que je peux être passé
à côté de quelque chose de très
important et ça je le regrette mais j'ai
envie envie moi je t'ai vu avec les
enfants notamment ta fille j'ai
l'impression qu'elle n'en veut pas du
tout et qu'elle est hyper heureuse
d'être avec toi je la vois qu'elle
viendrait une voir à l'émission
donc est ce que l'on est et non pas
reprocher mine de rien qui vaille non
mais puisque en plus j'ai pris six ans
j'ai plus été absent et mon fils parce
que j'étais à ce moment là je faisais
pas de télévision j'étais awfiyah rouge
des grands panthères j'étais souvent
étrangers j'étais pas là et puis j'ai un
petit je suis parti d'un ring back la
villa il a 26 ans
il a 26 ans et voilà je trouve qu'il est
parti du principe un peu vieux que
garçons plus rapidement c'est son envol
alors que voilà j'ai ma fille je suis
tout temps je l'aimais mais je pense
qu'à mon fils je n'ai jamais dit que je
l'aimais alors je pense évidemment je
l'aimais énormément mais je n'ai jamais
dit peut-être par pudeur comme j'ai dit
à mon père mais non plus il est parti
jusqu'à quand ils étaient malades de
l'hôpital jeunes il faut que juriste que
j'aime et j'ai pas réussi à lui dire
qu'à pareille c'est qu'il le savait j'ai
paris je savais que je l'aimais mais
j'ai pas mal c'est lui dire et tout ça
maintenant je sais qu'avec ma fille je
le corrige un affichage hellemmes
j'essaie de changer par les gens me jean
miss et c'est vraiment émouvant ce que
tu ce que tu nous racontes et 8 livres
et c'est pour ça que je t'aime
énormément et parce que tu es quelqu'un
de très sincères et
bonjour me juste c'est vrai que toi tu
étais extrêmement sensible et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je vois tu
étais très content d'être dans
l'émission mais est ce que tu aimerais
pas tu aurais pas aimé avoir quelqu'un
avec toi partager ta vie être amoureux
en ce moment pendant ce confinement ou
est ce que tu es bien comme ça s'il est
évidemment monsieur h c'est ça qui m'a à
qui il n'a qu'a causé ma chute un peu
c'est que je suis un peu à coeur
d'artichaut je suis hameau de l'amour
mais qu'on amoureux de l'amour en
général ça dure pas très longtemps parce
qu'on est on est passionnel et du coup
on se lasse assez vite et c'est
l'histoire qui durent pas très longtemps
mais c'est sûr que je me dis que là est
seul c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure
des solutions j'ai vu en trois semaines
ça fait combien de temps que les
confiner presque un mois mais moins
personnes j'ai vu une personne c'est
jimmy mohamed qui est venu chez moi
c'est un garçon que j'ai bien de moi
même maître qui sera avec nous
travaillons mais c'est la seule personne
que j'ai vu qui est venu chez moi c'est
lui avec sa femme doit porter une
sculpture sur glace déjà tu regrettes
mine de rien ne pas avoir dit des choses
plutôt à tes enfants tu avais envie de
leur dire plus je t'aime tout ça parce
que tu m'as les pouvoirs j'espère bien
sûr mais bien sûr bien sûr je vais la
voir mais je dis ça mais je le regrette
encore parce que quand je vois mon fils
je lui dis pas alors je le pense mais je
vais force à l'écrire par texto par
texto jeudi plus de choses mais on de
vive voix j'ai plus de machines
anciennes de l'ancienne génération si
c'est pas naturel chez moi c est ton
témoignage sur ton papa était était très
fort bonjour me merci en tout cas des
têtes d'être aussi aussi franc et de
donner autant de choses dans l'émission
j'ai bien sûr qu'on t'aime aussi écouter
battus des fontaines fort bon mathieu on
voit le jour mais qui a vraiment qu'ils
me disent nos amis les larmes aux yeux
parce qu'il est il est extrêmement
touchant mon jour nice pour ça que je
les aime aussi c'est un travail et quand
je me dis à chaque fois la bande les des
gens de coeur avec moi là c'est une
nouvelle bande 1 voilà parce que voilà
on fait on crée une nouvelle émission
tous les gens voilà ils ont un point
commun sélection extrêmement sensible et
ce sont je pense voilà des gens bien mon
mathieu tour à toi aussi tu assistes ça
te fait réfléchir tout ça le le
confinement tout ça ou pas du tout bas
beaucoup parce que tu te rends compte
qu'en fait chaque jour tu as vu beaucoup
de choses tu vas faire du sport tu vas
tu vas tu vas travailler tu travailles
jusqu'à neuf heures du soir parce
qu'ensuite une fuite eut fui depuis
beaucoup de choses et quand tout d'un
coup tout s'arrête
batmag en conscience de ce qui reste et
ce qui reste c'est qu'ils rien dire que
quand le travail s'arrête
bah tu te dis j'ai pas de famille gg
personne dans ma vie et j'ai raté une
autoroute quoi j'ai rien construit je
suis tout seul et c'est vrai que je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
d'y réfléchir parce que je me dis le jeu
ma carrière on peut dit mais mon
parcours s'arrêtera c'est le à côté qui
va me créer une stabilité et la côte et
il est nul
donc effectivement c'est très bien
décédé à s'acheter une belle voiture et
d'essayer de gagner de l'argent et de
travailler mais je pense que c'est pas
ça le vrai truc son coach en train de
réfléchir actuellement c'est pas ça le
vrai truc je pense que de vraies
réussites telles et pas professionnel
est de créer quelque chose autour de soi
et et je vois bien que ça a été un échec
total jusqu'à maintenant
donc ouais je me remets et puis tu ça y
est cette fameuse phrase qui disait
toujours le premier mec avec qui tu es
si ça se passe pas ça qu'on le deuxième
simple qu'on le troisième sa courbe ou
du quatrième ça veut dire que le concept
wah wah libre et honnête je pense que si
tu tout seul à 46 ans que j'ai rien
construit je pense que j'ai pas été
assez généreux dans ma vie ça j'y
réfléchis beaucoup et à l'aîné rugby
journée truc tout bête penser aux
anniversaires des jantes et un sur
généreux la générosité c'est pas de
l'argent c'est penser aux autres
c'est ce qu'à des gens est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui vous ont déçu où il ya des
gens qui vous ont impressionné pendant
cette période de confinement et lyon
vous ai dit vraiment c'est incroyable il
ya des gens ou d'utiliser il m'a dit tu
vois là sont plus nombreux à vous si
vous voulez en cité mathieu par exemple
toi bon mathieu alors déçu déçu déçu non
et des gens qui m'ont alors je suis très
proche des gens me toujours on s'appelle
tous les jours je reconnais castaldi
tous les matins à 9 heures du matin
du coup de fil je reconnais que c'est
assez touchant aussi bien j'ai des gens
qui pour impressionner facettes cette
situation si tu délivres alors je vais
pas te mouiller la compresse comme on
dit mais si tu veux le jour dit j'ai des
gens d'âge de zoo de chez toi parce que
je parle à ta boite de prod et je leur
disais voilà syrie lamia à il est un peu
à l'abri financièrement il abrite
quelque chose ils auraient pu lui a
coûté les gars on arrête un moment sans
coupe tous et je reconnais que le fait
que l'émission ça fait travailler tous
les salaires est déj de dos à ne pas
travailler à nous aussi
ouais je pense qu'encore une fois les
grandes personnalités se révèlent dans
les grands moments je pense pas que ce
soit mon cas moi je pense que je suis
pas un [ __ ] fumée que dans les grands
moments je me rappelle pas non plus je
suis un mec normal et il ya d'autres
personnes qui se révèlent chez c'est
très agréable façon je vais te dire on
verra où on verra vraiment y aura un
avant et un après même si elle en est
sûre les gens avec qui tu es c'est
vraiment vraiment tu veux dire un seul
toit là dessus non moi je moi j'ai des
enfants j'ai la famille pas une nouvelle
coiffure qui est bien une nouvelle
coiffure je suis bien
je comprends mais je comprends ce que
disent les choses parce que moi depuis
deux ans depuis que tu m'a emmené dans
cette aventure je me suis un peu perdu
parce qu'entre le boulot le matin les
émissions et soir j'ai décroché de tout
le monde je voyais personne guidon
plusieurs fois je me suis énervé et
plusieurs fois tu m'as dit d'antalya
calme toi c'est que dattes et lait ne
t'énerve pas comme ça et si enfin la
famille bon c'est vrai que plusieurs
fois tu me dis toi et loïc aussi pour
bras droit on doit faire attention de la
famille et c'est vrai que dans le sol en
branle à cantat les enfants et les potes
c'est vrai que c'est super important
on va moins moi j'ai envie que voulez
vous que je vais apprendre à rené oui
parce que je pense que les gens pensent
peut-être compris potes qu'on dit le tpp
c'est une famille etc
mais moi que j'étais au figaro où je
pouvais être malade en cinq jours
personne maps et si ce n'est le rh pour
me demander quel jour je rentrais ou
plus envoyer mon certificat médical là
ici mais tous les jours benhaim tour on
s'appelle tous géraldine maillet on
s'appelle tous ceux que mal à donner
plutôt monde s'appelle tous les jouets
qui s'était passé après c'est des vrais
amis une traite famille c'est papy c'est
vrai on voyait tu voulais dire quelque
chose mon chéri oui mais moi mon jeu
c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas eu le même
parcours
j'ai pas eu le même parcours que j'ai
michel mathieu vraiment et je ne pourrai
pas assez pour savoir mais moi j'ai eu
une chance inouïe c'est que bon le fait
est que je me suis mariée jeune mais
j'avais des parents qui m'ont fait
comprendre qu'il fallait pas jouer quand
j'ai eu des jets des tas d'amis
je ne peux pas vivre sans amis si j'ai
pas d'amis je suis pas bien et j'avais
beaucoup beaucoup cité des amis pas
déconner ça faisait deux ans j'ai
beaucoup d'amis et j'ai une chance
inouïe d'avoir une femme ans
son principe qui est parti sur beaucoup
le choc
et pendant ce coq cinéma et je n'ai pas
le droit de ne pas le regretter à là
puisque le seule satisfaction est à côté
de moi et je m'ennuie de pas laisser ces
belles déclarations d'amour moment rené
sophie apprendre à jean mi to voulais
rajouter que je suis tout va c'est vrai
que ça remet beaucoup les choses en
perspective et moi je suis seul à la
maison parce que mon amoureux habite à
londres et puis de toute façon en vivre
ensemble
en temps normal et là je me retrouve
avec les trois garçons et c'est vrai ce
que tu disais ça révèle les tempéraments
et moi je découvre trois garçons
fantastique et à dire que je fasse pas
beaucoup de temps avec eux puisque le
matin je suis à la radio en direct le
soir je suis avec vous aussi
donc c'est vrai que je travaille
énormément en presse écrite par tous et
là de fait de les voir tout le temps et
ils ont une espèce de reconnaissance et
de gratitude par rapport à ce que je
peux faire
et merci maman et on t'aime maman était
le grand il a 19 ans à 13 ans et le
petit la 10 ans et ils sont franchement
ils sont super au début ça a été un peu
difficile parce qu'il faisait rien ils
n'ont pas compris que il va falloir se
bouger et maintenant j'ai même pas alors
dire ils font tout est ce qu'on peut
t'aider
c'est vraiment j'avais des gros ben moi
sourit oui j'ai envie d'y rajouter un
truc mon chéri oui je trouve ça très
rapidement j'ai parlé mon papa tout à
l'heure mais je vais en profiter pour de
crack ou quoi ma maman tu habites très
loin et surtout je lui ai jamais dit que
je l'aimais je lui dis ce soir je la
vole bien bravo bravo franchement il ya
plein de gens qui disent que c'était
hyper touchant voilà le témoignage du
jour me joly on vous accompagne tous les
soirs et vous êtes également notre
famille c'est une grande famille voilà
la famille s'est vite voilà on sait une
nouvelle émission s'appelle ce soir chez
by vous êtes une famille vous nous
rejoignez tous les soirs merci en tout
cas d'être avec vous